this would be a lesson that our friends
over in the GOP might be able to figure
out the sort of people who have
empowered in the GOP for a very long
time I might be able to figure out if
they had an ounce of self-awareness but
they don't so instead they're blaming
Lauren bobert but we have Lauren on the
call Lauren thank you so much I know
you're very very busy right now but
thank you for making time to come on the
show
absolutely thanks so much for having me
on Michael so Lauren where does it all
stand we've given a recap of of the the
speaker fight through last night on the
show Kevin McCarthy lost three rounds of
voting two days ago he loses three runs
of voting yesterday you and those
terrible evil House Freedom caucus
Republicans you're you're not budging
here so what happens
well let's begin at where it started
this started in the summer we wanted to
handle this privately
um and and have a solution before
January 3rd these negotiations began in
the summer and they were dismissed
because Kevin McCarthy thought he was
going to have this massive Red Wave and
our votes did not matter when he saw
that the 300 million dollars that he
raised did not produce the red wave that
he promised he realized quickly he's
going to need our votes and so some
concessions
um were were put into play it was very
difficult to get them into play it was
difficult to get them approved with our
rules process the Way Washington DC
operates and functions we want to
fundamentally change this town it is
broken it is less popular with the
American people than cockroaches so we
have to get something right here and we
cannot go along with the status quo well
on January 2nd um two of my fellow
colleagues and myself Matt Gates Scott
Perry we walked into
leader McCarthy's office after whipping
votes all day long and handed him 218
votes we said here it is let's seal the
deal here's some common sense issues
that you can put forward some promises
that you can make single member motion
to vacate so there is accountability on
the third in line to the presidency of
the United States you cannot demand more
responsibility and follow Nancy Pelosi's
precedence of less accountability so
this is our check and balance on the
speaker and that was a priority for me
personally certainly and for many others
but then things like bring the Texas
border plan to the floor for a vote
bring a term limits Bill to the floor
for a vote any member who wants to
reduce spending in an amendment will
make that amendment in order so we can
bring it to the floor and have a vote
earmarks bring them to the floor
individually for a vote this is spending
money that we do not have so let's at
least have a vote on it instead of
packing it into a bill where we have no
option to either swallow the whole thing
or say no way
um these are things that we presented to
him he uh solicited a list from us of
committee assignments all members
provide committee assignment requests we
know where our talents and skills are
are best utilized and we provided that
list Kevin McCarthy made a great
argument saying listen the people in
this group only want two committees I
need you spread out I want you to have
more influence and we agreed with that
and we said you know this is a time
constraint on many of the members that's
a lot of responsibility a lot of
pressure but we're willing to take that
sacrifice and have these committee
assignments that bear more pressure and
so we've provided that to him and then
January 2nd when all of that was laid on
the table foreign
McCarthy laughed us out of the room said
that it was a selfish wish wish list and
would not take the deal well now here we
stand Michael I no longer have those 218
votes to provide to Kevin McCarthy so it
doesn't matter if I go to the floor
today and vote for Kevin McCarthy
because there are now more than ever
votes that he does not have to get to
that speakership this is very important
to know he walked out of that meeting
and lied about what we requested trust
is absolutely broken if there were if
there was any to begin with and this is
a huge problem we want unity in the
Republican party and I believe now is
the time to start seriously considering
consensus candidates who will unify the
Republican party so we can get to work
for the American people this is really
important context I think because what
you're saying is over the summer
leader McCarthy just didn't think he
needed you guys because there were
supposed to be more Republicans in the
house and so he would be able to win the
speakership without having your votes
along
because of what happened that turned out
to be a Bad Bet and when you make bad
bets you got to pay the price for those
bad bets and and you bring up this other
point which is trust and I think this is
really important because a lot of this
debate has focused on how on the issues
Kevin McCarthy is relatively pretty good
you know we come from a world of John
Boehner's so I guess Kevin McCarthy is
more conservative than John Boehner but
but what you're saying is no it's really
about
trust when we're talking about
leadership elections we need to be able
to trust the leader and and what you're
saying is you don't think that leader
McCarthy has proven himself trustworthy
correct and that's why we wanted the
tools implemented
um to where maybe we don't need to trust
him because the individual member is
empowered enough to get the job done and
is not ruled by a dictator as a speaker
this is not a kingdom that we live in we
don't anoint a king I believe that this
is how our founding fathers intended
this process to work our vote is there
to be debated not just rubber stamped
and cast to the biggest fundraiser but
you cannot have good faith negotiations
where trust is absent and so that's why
motion to vacate was so important to me
because that is the check and balance on
this position if you break trust if you
don't do what you promised well buddy
you're out of there and he has already
shown he's not willing to do that I
still have not seen a a public
announcement of a single member motion
to vacate he's lying to me for those
listening who don't know what that is
what is a motion debate take it
a motion to vacate gives us the
opportunity to remove the speaker and
have another vote for speaker if
necessary this is something that does
not get used but it's available this is
something Thomas and Thomas Jefferson
um wrote and has been in effect for
nearly two centuries and Nancy Pelosi
was the first speaker in history to
modify that she removed that individual
empowerment from the from the member and
uh and said you no longer have a say in
this I get to rule how I want and you
don't have a check you don't have a
balance Kevin McCarthy wanted to leave
that as Nancy Pelosi had it there were
concessions he got down to 50 he got
down to 20 got down to five no Thomas
Jefferson wrote it as one member any one
member can bring that motion to vacate
the chair forward and that is our
accountability this is something that
was my red line and I've only heard from
a staff member who chased us out of the
GOP conference and begged us to vote for
Kevin McCarthy we'll give you single
member motion to vacate and I said
that's adorable where's Kevin saying it
so so that I guess this is now where the
rubber meets the road and I know you're
short on time so
what happens after all of this context I
mean I think you've explained your
position very very well I think that
it's it is pretty clear that leader
McCarthy he just he thought he had the
votes and he didn't have the votes and
this actually the same thing happened in
2015 let's not forget Kevin McCarthy was
The Heir Apparent after John Boehner he
didn't have the votes and that's how
Paul Ryan emerged as the compromise
candidate so so what happens what could
Kevin McCarthy come out and say right
now that would win over your votes and
maybe the votes of your colleagues in
the freedom caucus or
if there's nothing that he could say
who who would you support today I know
that this is a little bit in flux but
who would you support today to replace
him
right so we have been offering a menu of
other candidates
um I I don't believe that my my
switching to Kevin McCarthy matters
because there are so many who are
solidly Kevin you can issue in a public
apology you can change all the rules you
can wear a straight jacket and and just
have a portrait that says that your
speaker and we get to run this place and
they're not going to vote for Kevin
McCarthy so at this point we do have to
start looking forward to other other
candidates and I can name 200 who are
potential candidates right out of the
conference GOP I'm excluding myself so
that's why that number is 200 and
Kevin's excluded as well
um but you know this this is something
that we have to start talking about we
presented
um Jim Jordan's Jim Jordan we have
presented Andy Biggs we've presented
Byron Donalds
um I've heard Jim Banks name be voted on
in in these during these votes maybe
it's someone outside of Congress maybe
it's a Lee zeldin who actually won US
the majority without his efforts in New
York running for governor we wouldn't
have the majority and maybe it's it's
someone who is in the conference
um like a Kevin Hearn who is currently
chairman of the Republican study
committee which is the largest caucus in
the Republican conference he was
unanimously elected with 173 votes to
chair that committee and he actually has
a balanced budget that he wants to put
on the floor which is another thing that
Kevin denied in our proposal on January
2nd so maybe it's someone like that who
already has the trust of the conference
and can truly get to 218. Before I Let
You Go Lauren
is is the trust now just irreparably
broken that is to say if Kevin McCarthy
came out and issued a statement said
okay I'll give you a single member
motion to vacate okay I'll give you this
that or the other thing one would that
change your vote and two
would that change enough votes to to put
him into the speakership I know you've
suggested maybe not but but just to be
totally clear are you saying that
from the people you're talking to
McCarthy's speaker candidacy is is
actually dead
it's dead yes the nails are in the
coffin and uh there are plenty of
members who are cheering our efforts on
who are afraid of Retribution
um we were threatened in conference it
was it was a nightmare in there we were
threatened
um by steering
um committee members who who actually
assign committees to members of Congress
that um if we vote against Kevin at all
we will not receive committee
assignments and Kevin McCarthy
affirmed that he stood up and said your
District elects you your conference
elects what committee you are assigned
to
um and so trust is broken as it stands
for me I am a no on Kevin and there are
too many others who are there uh who
don't allow him to get to 218 he doesn't
have the numbers Michael
wow that's that's really really big and
I have to tell you I know that people
are pulling their hair out over this
especially in the establishment GOP
to me this is positive constitutional
republic at work this is it this is kind
of how it works and if you're going to
make bets in politics then you got to
make sure those bets pay off or you're
going to pay the price and if you if you
want a leadership role I know you
recently had an interview on television
where where the host who will remain
unnamed was yelling because he said well
Kevin McCarthy has 200 votes you only
have 20 votes well I thought you made
the point very well the first test of a
congressional leader someone who is in
leadership someone who's The Speaker of
the House is
can you get the votes that it takes to
put you into the office because the
whole job is getting the votes and
creating consensus Lauren thank you so
much for taking the time today I will be
waiting with popcorn maybe with some
booze as cat kamek suggested people do
to to see how this fight uh plays out
thank you for coming on thank you so
much and I do believe that history is
going to show that we are on the right
side of this we're going to get it right
all right thank you Lauren we are
heading over to the member block right
now so do not go anywhere
unless you're not a daily wire member
then you've got to head on over to
dailywire.com right now subscribe become
a member we'll see you over at the
member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]